PROFESSOR: Today we're
going to continue
our theme of linkage
folding, but we're
going to generalize
our notion of linkage.
And so we want to go
beyond folding just
one-dimensional structures
in two dimensions, which
is what we've been talking
about the last two classes
for the most part.
We did a little bit in 3-D.
But Carpenter's Rule theorem is
about unfolding these things.
We talked about
locked trees, when
you add degree
three vertices here.
I want to make things a
little harder and more
interesting by adding fat
objects to those edges.
So these are solid regions.
You could think of
them as polygons,
but they could also be smooth--
whatever, lines, circles,
whatever you want.
They're still hinged at
points, and they still
fold like this
underlying linkage.
But now the collision
constraint is even worse.
Not only are the bars
not allowed to touch,
but these blobs that
are attached to the bars
are not allowed to
cross each other.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it kind of
like a rigid sub-linkage?
PROFESSOR: Yeah
it's kind of like,
say this was a polygon
because everything's almost
a polygon-- everything's
linear to the first order.
So you could just
triangulate this guy
and say, yeah that's just like
a more complicated linkage.
Now this moves as
a rigid object,
and it can't collide
with anything else.
You can even over-brace it if
you want-- add lots of bars--
but it will move the same.
Of course, then you
have collisions,
so that's kind of cheating.
But if you triangulate, you
will get the same behavior
as these rigid objects, yeah.
Now, we know that
as soon as you go--
as soon as you have a vertex
of degree more than two,
things can lock.
So it's no surprise that
these things can lock.
What's surprising is that you
can prove interesting things
about them not locking.
Let's start with some simple
examples of them locking.
So these are triangles
hinged together
at points that are locked.
And this field
began back in '98.
This is when we were
working on locked trees.
Marty, our cameraman, was
working on locked triangles,
and after a day he came
up with these examples.
They're not too hard to find.
This is probably the
most compelling one.
You have on the top
those obtuse triangles.
And because they share
an edge like that,
they can really
only hinge one way.
They can only close this angle.
They can't open it, and
so this guy's stuck.
It can't get out.
This is a little
trickier, but what's
interesting about
this example is
all the triangles
are equilateral.
It's pretty special.
If you were hoping for
some good results here,
you think, well
equilateral triangle.
Those are the simplest,
nice shapes I know.
So maybe they work.
But they don't work.
They can lock.
This may be a
little less obvious
because this guy's
reaching around on the top,
can't unwind if this is
drawn sufficiently tight.
And in fact, it's pretty
obvious because we
could apply rule one right here.
It's an edge spanned
by two acute angles,
so that glues in there.
Then you have a rigid triangle
here, so that stays co-linear
and then you're screwed.
Then the only thing that could
move is that top triangle,
and it can't get out.
So the self-touching
version is rigid,
and therefore any perturbation
is strongly locked.
So we can use the same tools we
did-- because you could ignore
the fact that these
are solid things.
So just think of them as
triangles, as linkages.
And we could still use
rules one, and two,
and rigidity, and
strongly locked, and all
those good things, and prove
that these things are locked.
And we'll do that some later.
But I claim it's useful to
think about rigid shapes being
attached to bars.
Because in particular, we know
how to unfold things like this.
So maybe there are
certain kinds of shapes
that you could attach.
Maybe if I just thickened
it a little bit,
maybe that wouldn't
matter too much.
We know that if you add
equilateral triangles,
that can lock.
But what if I add some
very small, thin triangles
to these edges?
Well then it turns
out you can't lock
for the appropriate
definition of thin.
So this is the idea of
an adorned chain, where
you have rigid shapes
attached to bars.
So the bars guide the motion.
We're going to think
about the underlying
linkage, the
underlying chain here,
and then there are these
rigid shapes attached to them.
They come along for the ride.
And in particular-- blah,
blah, blah, all right
we have some terminology.
An adornment in general
looks something like this.
This is rigid region,
but it has this segment
marked on it called the base.
The rest is the shape.
So as the bar moves,
you just rigidly move
the shape so that the base
lines up with the bar.
And that's how
they follow along.
And now we can define
the notion of thin,
except we call it slender.
A little nicer.
The best thing
about mathematics is
you get to make up terminology.
Not the best thing,
but a cool thing.
At some point, my dad was
having dinner with a group
and saying, yeah that's great.
We've made up all
these fun words
like slender on
un-unfoldable which
is something we'll talk about.
And it's like what words
have you guys made up?
And one guy raised his
hand an said, oh, Ethernet.
We're not that cool.
All right, so what does
slender adornment mean?
It's going to be shapes
more like these thin things.
Maybe even these, I think,
but not so much this.
That doesn't look
so slender to me.
What we're going
to do is walk along
the boundary from one base
endpoint to the other.
So let me draw an example here.
I think that'll be slender.
So we start here, we walk
along in this direction.
And what we want is that this
motion, as you walk along
there you monatonically increase
your distance to the endpoint
you started at, the
former endpoint.
And also, sort of equivalently,
you decrease the distance
to the other endpoint, the
one you're approaching.
And this should be true no
matter how you get there.
So I'm walking in this
along this outer boundary,
and I'm looking.
What is the distance
to this end point?
I can just draw a whole
bunch of concentric circles
around that point.
As long as these circles only
hit my curve once, I'm happy.
That means this distance is
increasing monotonically.
But you should also draw
them from the other side.
It's like offset curves, good
old straight skeleton stuff.
And lo and behold,
you monatonically
move outward from here if you
went this direction, outward
from here if you
went that direction.
And this should be true for
both sides of the curve.
This one looks like, yeah.
It monotonically
increases distance
from here, decreases from there
as you move right to left.
That's slender.
Pretty simple definition.
The biggest slender shape you
could hope for-- the biggest
one that you can do-- is if you
draw one giant circle centered
at each of the
points, and passing
through the other endpoint.
That's slender.
I know it looks pretty fat.
This is like a
Reuleaux triangle,
but that's still slender.
And if you go outside
that, you're in trouble.
Then you won't be monatonic.
If I went here and came back,
I'm getting farther away,
but then I'm getting
closer again to this point.
So that's not allowed.
Cool, so that's
slender adornments.
There's actually a couple of
different ways to define it.
And-- yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Can you fit
an equilateral triangle
within that?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So I don't mean to say that
if you take any-- you can fit
an equilateral triangle
in there, I think.
Well, like this.
An equilateral triangle
is not slender.
We can check that.
I know it's weird.
It's not a monoton definition.
If you take a subset
of your slender shape,
the result will not
necessarily be slender.
So if we do equilateral,
if you draw a circle--
there's a circle here that's
going to kiss this edge.
It's centered here and it kisses
this edge of the triangle.
So that means you're going
out and then coming back,
getting closer again.
So equilateral triangle
is not slender.
That's good, because we know
equilateral triangles can lock.
So it better not be slender,
because I'm going to say that
slender chains cannot lock.
That's what we're
going to prove.
I
Let me give you
another definition.
It's a little bit
easier to work with
and also gives some
intuition about why
slender things are good.
Well, it will give some
intuition, not immediately.
If you look at inward
normals from the shape,
then they hit the base.
This is assuming that my
shape is somewhat smooth,
but it's not a big deal.
So let me take a
nice shape again.
If I look, here's a tangent,
here's an inward normal.
I extend it, it hits the base.
All of these inward
normals hit the base.
That's good.
In this case, I could
take an inward normal from
here-- say, if you don't want
to do the corner because it's
a little confusing.
And you will go-- here
you don't hit the base.
You hit this line of course.
Unless you happen to be
parallel, you'll hit the line.
But I want it to actually
hit the line segment that
is the base of the shape.
And maybe go back up here,
the Reuleaux triangle,
you take one of the
inward normals here,
it will actually just
barely hit the base.
It hits it at a vertex.
That's, OK because
this is slender.
That's why if you went a
little bit outside, then
you'd have an inward normal
that doesn't hit the base.
So it's pretty
easy, given a shape,
to tell whether it is slender.
Just draw a bunch of inward
normals and it either works
or it doesn't.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If you make some
complex thing like that,
that's not going to be slender.
Now, you could take
something called the slender
hull-- I'll define
that in a moment.
Here's another definition.
It's a union of half-lenses.
Half-lenses I want to define
sort of like this Reuleaux
triangle example.
But I don't necessarily take
these vertices as the center.
I take some vertex
here as the center.
Let's say I take
two of them and I
draw a circle centered
here passing through here--
so that's like this--
a circle centered here
passing through here--
that's like this.
I'm getting better
at drawing circles.
That's my half-lens.
If I drew the whole thing,
that would be a lens.
So you get a choice.
Now I could maybe choose
this point and this point
and draw a circle here and here.
And then there's
another half-lens.
If you take a whole bunch of
those, union them together,
that will always be slender.
That's kind of
obvious, because you
look at any of these
inward normals,
they're going to
hit one of these
x's that you drew on the line.
What's a little less obvious
is that every slender shape
can be made by a
bunch of these things.
Now admittedly, possibly
infinitely many of them.
If my shape-- one of my
favorite slender shapes
is a right triangle.
And you can check all the
inward normals hit the base.
Here they just
barely hit the base.
Obviously you need an infinite--
all of these half-lenses
are curved.
But if you take an appropriate
infinite number of them, namely
all the points here, there
is a lens that covers it.
You just take all of those--
I'm not drawing them perfectly,
but they'll look
something like that.
You take the union
of all of those,
that'll give you the triangle.
So in fact, any shape
you want to make slender
you take the lens
that hits every point.
So this is the slender hull.
If you have some shape
that's not slender,
this is really ugly, they're
inward normals that go up.
But I can fill it
in, I don't know
exactly what this
will look like.
But for example, this
point is kind of bad.
It's got an inward
normal going up.
So I'll take the slender hull.
I'll take some-- did I lie?
I think it's even simpler.
Let me check.
Yeah, I was more
complicated than I
have to be for half-lenses.
This does work, it'll
still be slander.
But you can be-- in
fact, because you
need to be monotonic the
whole way around, you
might as well always use
these two points as centers.
It's been a while since
I've seen this stuff.
So if I had some
point like this,
it'd be a little bit nicer if
I took circle centered here,
and a circle centered way over
there so it's almost vertical.
That's also half-lens.
That will be smaller.
I can, of course,
add more stuff later,
but that's the minimum
you can get away
with is that half-lens.
If I want to add
this point, it's
going to be something like that.
Circle centered here and
here, and that's my half-lens.
So that actually
uniquely defines
what you want to do here, which
is you take a circle centered
at this point, you take a
circle centered at this point,
and you add that to your shape.
And so in general,
in this example
it's going to fill in
something like that.
This might be OK.
It might fill in
a little bit here.
It's going to fill in something.
So then this shape
will be slender.
So if you have some shape
that's not quite slender,
and it's messy and ugly, you
could fill it in like this.
And as long as that
fill-in doesn't intersect
with any other shapes,
you're still OK.
So if you have some crazy
collection of shapes,
you fill them in with
the slender hull,
and they're still not
self-intersecting,
then you know that thing
will not be locked.
Of course, if the fill-in
doesn't intersect,
and you can move it
without intersection,
then the original
thing won't intersect.
So that's good.
Now of course, if you have
crazy interlocked shapes,
well those are
going to be locked.
So you're in trouble.
Something like this.
And then when you take the
slender hull, you'll see,
oh they're overlapped so I don't
know what's going to happen.
Of course, we're not going
to be able to characterize
every collection of shapes
that lock, slender gives you
a pretty good idea
of when they do,
when you're guaranteed safe.
Oh, I think I even
have to a figure
of a whole bunch
of slender things.
On the top we have mostly
half-lenses-- actually
they're all symmetric.
In this case, I took
lenses, not half-lenses,
but you could just take the
upper half or the bottom half.
You can take regular Kgons,
circles, half circles,
Reuleaux triangles, various
combinations thereof.
Lots of shapes are slender.
You can take this
on one side and this
on the other side of the
edge, whatever you want.
Or just put an
adornment on one side.
Many things are slender.
So we want to prove, if
you have a slender chain,
you are not locked.
That's the theorem
from 2006 originally.
The journal version
just appeared.
And the way we're going to prove
that-- as you might guess--
is using the Carpenter's
Rule theorem.
We have this underlying chain,
we know how to unfold that.
Maybe if we're lucky,
slender adornments
won't mess up the
Carpenter's Rule of motion.
And in general, if you take an
arbitrary unfolding of a chain,
you have no idea
what's going to happen.
Maybe the shapes will
intersect each other.
Your motion could be annoying.
But the Carpenter's
Rule theorem tells
us, not only is there a motion.
There's a nice motion
that's expansive.
And it turns out, as long as
you have an expensive motion
of what I call the underlying
chain, then that motion will
not cause any of the
pieces to intersect.
Assuming they don't
initially, then
that nonintersection will
be preserved, provided
your adornments are slender.
So that means, if we have
some slender chain, slenderly
adorned chain, say open chain,
then via an expensive motion
which we know exists
you'll be able to unfold
the chain straight.
And then if you want
to go somewhere else,
you can unfold that somewhere
else straight, and then glue
those motions together, and you
get your motion from a to b.
Let me start with
an intuitive proof.
Suppose you have two slender
shapes that are touching.
Suppose you're moving around.
If they're going to cross,
first they have to touch.
So consider the moment
at which they touch.
I claim they can't
cross from there.
And the intuition
is the following,
take an inward normal from--
when they touch like this,
they have a common tangent.
And so if you take the
inward normal on both sides,
those inward normals
are co-linear.
And you know from the
second definition--
I didn't prove they're
all equivalent,
but they are-- that we will
get some points on the bars,
on the edges, on the bases.
So what?
Well, if I take
two bars-- and I'm
computing expansive motions,
meaning I know this distance
increases, this
instance increases,
this distance increases,
and this distance increases.
Those are the struts
that we added.
It turns out-- I've
actually used this
once before, I
think-- that in effect
if you take any two
points on the bars,
that distance also
has to increase.
It's pretty obvious, because
these are straight things.
If any point here was going
to approach any point here,
you would need to either
move this point closer
to the this edge or this
point closer to this edge.
And if you move a point
closer to an edge,
one of these two edges will get
shorter and that's now allowed.
So if all four of
those cross distances
increase, then in
fact the distance
between any two
points on the segment
increase or stay the same.
Remember, in general
we're expansive.
There's some pairs that you
cannot strictly increase
the distances of, although
most of them we can.
And so that's good news.
If this distance increases,
it's pretty hard for them
to start intersecting there.
This is an intuition,
not quite a proof.
You can make this into a
formal proof, it's just messy.
The trouble is, for
example, if the distance
stays the same you can kind
of spin around that point.
You can move first
order left or right.
Maybe it's not actually
this point from this guy
and this point from this guy who
are going to start penetrating,
because as you move maybe
it's some point nearby
that falls inside.
It's a little tricky to see
who exactly can intersect what.
It looks good.
And in particular, if
this distance is strictly
increasing, then it pretty
much has to move away.
But there's a lot
of subtle details,
and it's kind of a mess.
We did it once.
But in fact, we
found a simpler proof
that does not have
to rely on this.
But I still like this from
an intuitive standpoint.
It's kind of clear why that
inward normal property is good.
If the inward normals
hit outside the bar, then
you have no idea whether
that distance expands.
As long as it hits
inside, you're golden.
Let's start with a special case
that's really easy to prove.
It's easy to prove by
appealing to fancy mathematics.
They're actually pretty
old mathematics from 1934.
There wasn't a lot of math then,
and yet some great results.
So let's start with a symmetric
case, where you have your base,
you have some slender
adornment, and you
have exactly the reflection
of the slender adornment
drawn below it.
So it's reflectionally
symmetric about that line.
That's nice, because
instead of having
to worry about half-lenses I
can worry about entire lenses.
Like a special
case, every time I
have some lens like this one--
it should look like that,
a circle centered here,
circle centered here,
that would be the half-lens--
I have in fact the entire lens.
So really if this shape is going
to intersect some other shape,
then there's got to be
some lens over here that's
going to intersect
some other lens.
So really I can just
think of a single lens,
pretty much, worry about
one lens hitting another.
In the symmetric case, it turns
out-- what do I want to say?
This preserves not in
[INAUDIBLE] section.
It turns out, not only is
nonintersection preserved
under continuous motions,
which is what we care about,
it's preserved for what I'll
call instantaneous motions.
In the origami context, we
would call these folded states.
We don't worry about how
you got there, you just
draw it again differently.
It's like you instantaneously
jumped to that point.
So in terms of
configuration spaces,
we have some big
configuration space.
And we say, well ideally
I go somewhere by motion,
but maybe I just jump
over to another point.
I just redraw these
symmetric slender adornments.
And I should say, the
motion should still
be expansive in the
sense that if you measure
the distance between two
vertices in the original
and you measure the
distance between them
in the new resulting
configuration,
the distance only goes up.
It could stay the same
or strictly increase.
So this is kind of crazy.
You don't even need
continuity for this the hold
in the symmetric case.
So in general we're
worried about some lens.
The lens is going to be
symmetric about this line,
but not necessarily
about this line.
We're worried about
it intersecting
some other lens
when that happens.
Well, here's a cool theorem.
And this theorem has come into
fashion in the last few years.
Actually, let me tell
you a bigger result
called the Kneser
Poulsen Conjecture.
It's a conjecture I don't
know how many years ago.
It's also called,
pushing disks together.
I have a bunch of
disks in the plane.
Suppose they overlap,
who knows what
happens, but a bunch of disks.
And then I push
them all together,
meaning the opposite
of expansion.
All the centers of the disks
get closer to each other.
Is it the case that the area of
the union, or the intersection,
all these things should go down.
It seems intuitive
enough, but was
unsolved until 2002,
someone recent.
A special case of that
turns out to be all we need.
There's obviously disks
lying around here.
This is the intersection of
two disks, so it seems useful.
Overall, there's four
disks involved here.
There's one here, one here,
one here, and one here.
What we really care about
are four-way intersections
between all four of those disks.
That would be bad.
That would be the two
lenses hitting each other.
Remember, really there's
a bigger edge here.
But if they're going to hit,
some two lenses have to hit.
And that special case
is much older, 1934.
And it says, if
we instantaneously
translate-- you can't
really rotate disks,
it doesn't change much.
Let's say we have n disks,
and we instantaneously
just move them around.
And I'm going to state
it in the expansive form.
And suppose initially
they have no intersection,
meaning they have an
empty n-way intersection.
And we instantaneously
translate to an expansive motion
on the centers, then
we'll still have
an empty n-way intersection.
Now, in our case we
care about n equals 4.
We have four disks
we care about,
we somehow move
them so the centers
are the vertices of my chain.
We don't even need that
[INAUDIBLE] about other points.
I know the centers of my
lenses are my endpoints.
I know all those distances
are increasing somehow.
And now I'm even thinking
about the instantaneous case.
So I just pick up all those
points, drop them down so
all the distances
increase, then the theorem
is, if those four disks
didn't intersect before,
they still won't intersect.
Therefore, the lenses
don't hit each other ever,
even when you can pick things
up and drop them back down.
Done.
That covers what we need.
Now, I didn't
prove this theorem.
I don't think it's
too hard, but it's not
folding related so I'm just
going to take it as given.
But that was just
one special case.
That's when we had lenses
instead of half-lenses.
In reality we have
half-lenses so there's
a little bit more work to do.
Well, if the slender chain
is going to intersect itself
by some expansive motion--- oh,
by the way, the general case,
you need a continuous motion.
It doesn't work anymore when
you do it instantaneously.
I have a nasty example here,
sort of an annoying example.
Suppose you take a bar, and
you take the Reuleaux triangle
or just something really big,
and you have another bar here
with no adornment.
And now I instantaneously
move it to the configuration
where I have the same--
this guy didn't move.
I just put this guy
here or something.
So if I measure this
distance, it increased
but it's now self-intersecting.
So if you pick things
up and drop them down,
it doesn't work in
the general case.
That's because this
wasn't symmetric.
If it was symmetric, then this
guy was already intersecting.
But we can nonetheless prove
for the case we care about,
which is continuous
motion-- because we
know there's a continuous
expensive motion-- we can still
prove that no two
half-lenses will intersect.
So now I worry about two
half-lenses intersecting.
A half-lens looks
something like this.
Sorry, that's a lens.
A half-lens looks like that.
It has three sides, in general.
This one's bounded
by a disk, this one's
bounded by a disk, this one's
bounded by a base segment.
So there's basically a bunch
of cases you could worry about.
You could worry about
two of these guys hitting
in the curvy parts,
so that's case one.
That we get-- what
did I call them?
The base.
I'm going to rename
this, because I
don't like the terminology
I'm using here.
Curvy, curvy.
There's the two straight sides,
and there's the two of each,
and there's the
four curvy sides.
Suppose they hit on
a curvy side of both?
Well, if they hit on
the curvy side of both,
this is a convex region.
I could actually just put back
the rest of the half-lens here
and the rest and
a half-lens here.
They still won't intersect,
because the bases are pointing
away from the intersection.
So this is actually covered
by the case we just did.
We know that if we can complete
it to a lens and still not have
intersection-- maybe it
intersects other parts,
but we know these guys
cannot intersect each other
because these entire lenses
couldn't intersect each other.
So case one's done.
Case two is about is easy.
It could be we have curvy
part meeting a base.
So we have this example
again, but now we
try to intersect with the
base of some other half-lens.
What should I do here?
Anything useful I can do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Think about
the points on that line
as they should be expansive.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, these points
are expansive from here.
AUDIENCE: Tiny, tiny lenses.
PROFESSOR: Tiny
lenses, good, good.
Screw this lens.
Yeah I mean, that
lens really does not
participate in this
intersection, right?
Think of this as if there
is no adornment there,
which is like you have lots
of tiny half-lenses there,
but there's just none.
It's an empty union of lenses.
This is obviously a
slender adornment.
There's no adornment.
If the original is
going to intersect,
this should also intersect.
And this one I can
actually extend and make it
a full lens, because I'm
intersecting on the top side
here.
These can't hit each
other by convexity.
Great, so this is a symmetric
lens, this is a lens,
this is a lens, symmetric case.
So we already know those guys
can't intersect each other.
We have in some a-- there
is a tiny lens here,
which is from that
circle and that circle.
And the point is, the four
circles defining those two
lenses cannot intersect.
So again, we're done
by the symmetric case.
The last case is actually,
I guess, the easiest one,
base to base.
Base to base is like this.
And yeah, there's
some adornments,
but the adornments don't
really play a role.
So you could imagine
erasing them and just
talking about the
tiny things again.
But really, this follows
just because the linkage
is expansive.
We already know that the linkage
will not self-intersect itself.
Particularly, this
distance is increasing
and this distance is increasing.
It's got to move away,
so that can't happen.
It could actually never
get to the touching point
if it started non-touching.
Done.
This proves that if you have
a slender adorned chain,
you take an
expansive motion, you
preserve non-self-intersection.
If you have an open chain
of slender adornments,
this is great because you can
straighten out your chain--
why don't I draw the picture.
If you want to
get from one shape
to some other drawing
of that same polyline,
pretend the links are
the same and pretend
there's all these slender
adornments that are the same,
you can straighten out
each one and then just play
this motion backwards,
and take this motion
to here, this motion to here.
This is something I call
the FedEx algorithm,
we were talking about
in the problem session,
because the original
idea of FedEx
is you send all packages to
one central FedEx location
then send them out to
where you want to go.
Crazy idea, but it
worked for quite awhile.
It's a little more
complicated now,
but still that spirit is there.
And someone was asking
in the problem session,
well what if you send a package
from one point in California
the your neighbor?
I was like, well yeah, then it
goes far away and comes back.
But for math, it's no
problem, no energy issue.
So this is great
for open chains.
It does not work for closed
chains, because closed chains,
there's more than one
convex configuration.
I could take that, I could
take something more squashed.
Now normally this is fine.
We haven't proved it, but
for regular closed chains,
you could actually get from
every convex configuration
to every other.
Maybe we'll prove that
in the polyhedra section
because it's easy
to prove there.
Believe that, but
once you start adding
adornments it ain't possible.
So for example, if
I take this thing
and I add some adornments to
just fill in all the space,
this is not so slender.
But you can even draw it
with it being slender.
There's no way I can
go from here to here.
That's not very convincing,
because there isn't even
a configuration like that.
Here's a more convincing one.
Suppose you have
a parallelogram,
and you have a right triangle,
and a right triangle.
And now I want to go to here.
If I was allotted
instantaneous motion,
this would be fine,
even be expansive.
Well, no it's not expansive.
This distance
increases, and that's
why this theorem doesn't apply.
But these are two
complex configurations.
I can't get from
one to the other.
So for closed chains,
this doesn't quite
prove the configuration
space is connected
and you have to worry about
the convex situations.
For open chains, it does.
Open problem, are there
any other adornments
like slender ones?
Or are slender
the most you could
hope for a general result?
Is there some shape that is not
slender, such that no matter
how you add them to
a chain you'd still
have a theorem like this
that they never lock?
I would guess slender's the
most you could hope for,
but I'm not sure.
One special case
we can understand
is the case of triangles.
We know equilateral
triangles are bad.
We know right
triangles are good.
We know obtuse
triangles are good,
because these are slender.
What if I take a triangle
that's slightly more than 90,
slightly less than 90 here?
I know if I go all the
way to 60, it's bad,
but what about
slightly less than 90?
Also bad.
That's not convincing yet.
This is equilateral triangles.
I've made it more
complicated example
here in order to get a couple
of properties, but one of them
is that all of the equilateral
triangles are the same size.
It's a little bit cooler.
You have to imagine
where the bars are.
There's a bar here, and
a bar here, and so on.
This is what it looks like
when it's self-touching.
And the reason I'm looking
at that is I think,
what if I shear
this whole picture
or scale it non-uniformly in y?
So make it taller.
Taller?
Shorter.
I make it shorter
first in this picture.
I'm going to make it
taller in a second.
I've got to correct things,
but all of these triangles now,
the base is along here.
This is the apex angle.
So here I made the apex
even smaller than 60,
just not the direction
I cared about.
But the point is,
this thing will
stay locked no matter
how you shear it.
And so here I have
a bunch of triangles
where the apex angles, you can
make them arbitrarily small.
So even if I-- no surprise.
If I have a super
pointy triangle,
you're going to be able
to lock them like this.
But also if you go
the other way and you
make this a kind of
more than 60 angle,
as long as it's less than
90 this will stay locked.
And to give you some
intuition, if it's less than 90
I can apply rule one here.
But as soon as that
angle reaches 90,
this apex will be 90,
and so then rule one
does not apply here.
I think it'll still
apply on the other side,
but it doesn't matter.
You really need both sides to
be acute for rule one to apply.
This example's
actually a little bit
messy to prove that it's locked.
You can apply the
rules down to here,
but then you're not able
to apply rules anymore.
Actually, you can't even do
it in the last one, I think.
Just up to here, so here
I have a nice acute angle,
here I don't have
an acute angle.
It's kind of annoying.
The best way that I know to
prove that this thing is locked
is to compute an
equilibrium stress that's
positive or negative
on all of the struts.
Remember, there's
little struts here
saying that this guy has to
move away from this corner.
Or if could slide
along the edges,
but it can't go
on the other side.
So you could do that,
it's kind of messy.
I will prove to you
a simpler example.
We already did the
first one, but here's
another equilateral
triangle example.
Even fewer triangles,
and also locked.
This one you can't
scale quite as nicely.
Actually, I could
give you a choice.
Which proof would
you like to see,
the easy one or the hard one?
Easy?
Hard?
One person for hard,
thanks Harrison.
I like easy proofs.
They're more exciting.
OK, first the hard part is
I have to draw the example.
If you want to see
the hard proof,
it's in the lecture notes.
I kept it in there.
This should be the same
as that, more or less.
Imagine self-touching.
We're going to prove
that it's rigid,
therefore any perturbation
is strongly locked.
What should I do?
AUDIENCE: Apply rules.
PROFESSOR: Apply rules, yes.
I like the rules.
I live by the rules.
The first rule of the rules
is don't talk about the rules.
No, we have rule one here.
The first rule of the
rules is apply the rules.
So we can apply rule one because
this is acute, this is acute.
OK, now I have to redraw.
I should really have one of
these in the problem set.
Applying rules is so much fun.
It's also easy to make mistakes.
That's a good
problem set question.
All right, these
are not touching.
I mean, I don't really
have to fill these in.
They're triangles, of
course they're rigid.
But now these are
fused together.
Can I apply any more rules?
I think so.
I've got to try
not to cheat here.
This looks like a
rule too, right?
This is an acute angle,
so this fused together.
I'm just going to redraw that.
This fused together.
Any others?
I guess that's it.
Now I've got to do something
other than rules, darn it.
Life is not so easy.
I'm going to look at-- this
is divine inspiration here.
Well, co-author
inspiration, I suppose.
I'm going to look at that
convex-- 1-2-3-4-5-- pentagon.
It's convex.
OK, not strictly.
There's a corner of angle 180.
Actually, there's a couple
of ways to prove this.
Just look at this
convex arm, open chain
on the edges of
the convex polygon.
What's the right way to do this?
I have a better argument.
It turns out, if you take a
motion of a convex polygon--
any motion must decrease
at least two angles.
And that's really
hard to do here.
You can't decrease this angle,
or this angle, or this angle,
of this angle, because you've
got this stuff in the way.
There's only one angle you could
maybe decrease, but actually
even that one's probably
not going to work.
And I have to decrease two
of them, contradiction.
So there's no motion
of this thing.
It's like those tightly
packed convex configurations.
You can't move from
here, just looking
at the inside of this thing.
The rest is all been rigidified.
Well, I guess there's one vertex
here, but once this is rigid,
then this triangle
is rigidly attached
to these three triangles.
So the whole thing is rigid,
and therefore from last lecture
it's strongly locked.
AUDIENCE: The lecture
notes say one angle?
PROFESSOR: The lecture
notes say one angle.
I should change it
to two, because I'm
more worried about this one.
But two is also true.
It also decreases
at least one angle,
but in particular
decreases two of them.
Where's the lecture notes?
So it turns out--
and this is something
we'll prove later, this is
theorem by Koshy, like 1800s.
If you have a convex polygon,
you move it, at least two
of the angles must decrease
and at least two of the angles
must increase.
In fact, well there's all sorts
of cool things you can prove,
but that's slated
for another lecture.
We'll see that in the future.
I want to move on to a
different cool topic, which
is hinge dissections.
Any questions about locked,
slender, or nonslender
adornments?
So for triangles, we
have a tight answer.
You need to be right or obtuse.
In general, slender works.
I don't know if other
things work, but guess not.
Oh, another open
question, locked squares.
Now, if you have squares
that are properly aligned--
I don't draw them very well--
so if the base of the square
is through the diagonal
of the square, that's
slender so those can't lock.
But if you allow
the base edge to be
along the side of
a square like this,
I take unit squares
in the plane.
Open question, are these locked?
It's probably
really easy, we just
haven't worked hard
enough in proving
that these things are locked.
So that's something we could
work on in the problem session.
These are examples
in this paper.
So, we conjecture
these are locked.
So there's some work to do.
It's a fun, fun toy question.
All right, hinge dissections.
The idea here is, if you look
at one of these adorned chains
we've been thinking about where
you have solid blocks hinged
together points, and you
think about them moving--
we've been thinking
about them moving
and when you can
move from shape a
to shape b or configuration
a to configuration b.
But in particular configurations
where they're touching,
you could imagine
erasing those cuts.
On the top I get a square,
and the bottom here I
get an equilateral triangle.
So we call this a
hinge dissection
from an equilateral
triangle to a square.
This one goes back
over a century
by this puzzle guy,
Henry Ernest Dudeney.
A natural question
is, can you do
this for any two polygons
of the same area?
You have to preserve area,
because unerasing-- fusing cuts
does not change the area.
Natural question,
we've been working
on this question
for about 10 years.
We started in 1999, and
the first thing we proved
is that you couldn't
do everything,
but if you pixelate
shapes it works.
So in this case,
we're not pixelating.
We're dividing our
shape into half squares.
It turns out, if you
take every-- so here I
have 32 half squares.
In the letter A, I also
So I want to go from
the square to an A.
It turns out, if you take
each of these half squares
and replace it by four
smaller half squares,
and I hinge the half squares
in this particular pattern--
you can check it.
It alternates in a
very regular pattern.
It will work that
way in the square,
it'll also work that
way in the letter A.
I don't actually know
for sure whether there's
a continuous motion
between these two
without self-intersection,
because these are not
slender adornments the
way I've drawn them.
But this is a hinge
dissection that
exists in all of these states,
the whole alphabet and numbers.
And it's just 128 pieces.
So that would actually
be really fun to animate.
I haven't tried to do that yet.
You can generalize that
to three dimensions.
I think I showed
this in lecture one.
Here we have solid blocks.
So this is like pixelating,
but it's just stretched.
And we have piano hinges,
about 1,000 blocks here,
and you can pick up your
gloves and reconfigure
the sculpture into
whatever shape you want.
The theorem is, you can make
it into any polycube, any shape
made out of-- not 1,000,
but 250 for 125, I guess.
You divide by 8 to make a 2 by 2
by 2 larger square, or a larger
cube.
It's a stretched
cube, but same thing.
And then you can make any
shape made out of those shapes.
That was the beginning.
This is not everything,
it's everything
up to some resolution, but we
would really like everything.
And in this class
three years ago,
we proved to you
can make anything.
I think I posed this question
in the very first problem
session three years
ago, thinking maybe we
can prove some special
cases, something interesting.
And then two or three
problem sessions
later, it started
to collapse and get
solved, which is super
exciting given that we've
been thinking about
this for 10 years.
So this is going to be a little
more general than two polygons.
And suggested by the
alphabet, there's
one hinge dissection
that can fold
into many different
shapes, not just two.
So you take any finite set
of polygons of the same area,
then there's one chain of
polygons hinged together
at points that can continuously
fold into all of those things
without self-intersection.
Now, how do you
think we're going
to avoid self-intersection?
Slender.
We've got this
great tool lined up
for proving the continuously
part of this theorem.
The other part requires
totally new ideas,
but continuously is
going to be easy,
because the name
of the game here
is we're given polygons
we want to make,
but we can make
them out of a chain
of arbitrarily many pieces.
So if we have some
change that is working
without the continuity,
we can cut those pieces
into smaller parts
until they're slender.
It turns out that's
going to be easy.
I'll come back to that.
The hard part is to do this
with ignoring continuous motion.
So there's this crazy idea.
It comes from Zack Abel who
is attending the problem
sessions this year, so
a bunch of you know him.
I guess number two
is the crazy idea.
Hinge dissections
are actually named
after something else
called dissections.
With dissections, you don't
care about hinging the pieces
together.
I take one shape,
I cut it into a lot
of parts-- that's
the dissecting.
I rearrange the parts however
I want-- rigid motions--
and then fuse together the
edges and I get another shape.
So there's no hinging
here, there's no folding.
And it's well known
since the 1800s
that dissections always exist.
I can give you a quick
idea of how that's proved.
You take some polygon and some
other polygon of equal area.
Just triangulate
both the polygons
because that always
makes life easier.
Still nothing's really
matching between these two.
If you take a
triangle, if you just
cut halfway up from the
base and then cut here,
you can even do this hinged.
You flip this around,
and flip this around,
you get a rectangle of half
the height of the triangle.
This is how you compute the
area of a triangle, right?
Very easy.
So do that for each
of these triangles.
Just cut them so
they make rectangles.
Do that here, do that here.
What you'll be left with is a
whole bunch of rectangles here
and a whole bunch
of rectangles here.
Still kind of a mess.
But there's this
crazy dissection--
which I won't be
able to draw, and I
didn't bring a picture of
it-- that you can basically
take a rectangle of
some height and make
it a rectangle of
some other height.
It's got to preserve area, so
maybe look something like that.
There is a dissection
from here to here.
It's not hinged,
but you can do it.
Believe me, this goes back
three centuries, or something.
Once you can do that, you can
take your pile of rectangles
here and just change them
all to have the same height.
It's got to be smaller, maybe,
than your original height.
But you just pick some
epsilon and make a whole bunch
of rectangles of epsilon height.
If you turn this into a
rectangle of height epsilon,
this into a rectangle
of height epsilon, each
of these into a rectangle
of height epsilon,
and then string
them together, you
get a super long rectangle
of height epsilon.
If you do the same
thing over here,
you will also get a
super long rectangle
of height epsilon
of the same length,
because they have the
same area overall.
So I can dissect this
into the rectangle,
I can dissect this into the
rectangle, now I just FedEx it.
Except here FedExing means
I take the cut pattern here,
I overlay it with
the cut pattern
on the other which could
square the number of pieces.
Tons of pieces in this
thing, but it works.
And you can get from any
polygon to any polygon
using those gadgets.
What I want to focus
on is the hinging.
Hinging is where the
action is for us folders.
And this was the open
problem for a long time.
The crazy idea is,
hinge arbitrarily.
Oh, that was two shapes.
If you want k shapes,
you just overlay
k of those cut patterns.
You'll get some
collection of pieces
that can be reassembled
into your desired polygons,
your target polygons here.
Of course, not by hinging,
and definitely not
by hinging arbitrarily.
Like you pick a piece, you hinge
it to any other piece you want.
I don't care which
piece, you just
keep hinging all
these pieces together.
It's insane.
How could this possibly work?
Well, by steps three and four.
Only two steps to go.
This is the crazy idea.
For a long time we tried
to mimic this proof
but make all the
steps hingeable.
What's hard about that is,
even if one step is hingeable,
like the triangle
to a rectangle,
you can't really
combine two hingeings.
You can't FedEx.
You can't do one thing
and then the other.
You don't have transitivity,
because one hinging may not
be compatible with
the next hinging.
So instead of trying to make
it all work hinged all the way,
we just let it not
work and then fix it.
Great idea.
The way we're going to
fix it is by subdividing
the pieces, which will mean
we have to add more hinges.
And step three is, do
this to make it work.
So in some sense we know how
we want to assemble the pieces.
That's what the
dissection tells us,
that's what step one tells us.
That if you arrange
the pieces like this,
it'll give you the
polygon you want.
Somehow I want to make each
of those assemblies valid.
I'm going to do
that one at a time.
I'm going to enable
the first one,
then enable the
second one, and so on.
I could actually
get one for free.
Instead of hinging
arbitrarily, I
could hinge to make
the first one right.
I just draw it as they are, and
then just somehow add hinges
to connect it all together.
But I won't even
worry about that.
I'll just make it
work for the first one
and make it work
for the second one.
This is not going
to be efficient,
I should mention that.
Not particularly efficient.
The fourth step is,
make it slender.
And we're going to use the
same trick of subdividing,
and that will solve that.
I haven't said much yet.
Just now we have a plan.
We need some gadgets, and
here's where I get way
beyond the pictures I
could draw on the board.
This I could draw on the board,
but the picture to come I
could not.
So here's a general picture.
Let's say we have some
hinging in some arrangement.
We really want it
to be different,
so we're committed to
having a hinge here
and committed to
having a hinge here.
We can never remove
hinges, otherwise
we'll break previous
constructions.
But what I can do is cut up
the pieces and add more hinges.
As long as it can
still fold this way,
I can still make everything
I could make before.
I just also want it to be
able to fold into this.
This does not look
like a folding.
Here I'm detaching
the green thing from B
and reattaching it to
B prime on the top.
So I just shifted
the orange thing down
and reattached the green
at B prime instead of B,
at the same vertex A.
This is not everything
I need, but this will
be really useful.
If I could do this, I'll
be able to do everything
in a couple steps.
So let me show you
how to do this.
Watch.
So this is dissection.
We're going to cut out a lot
of little isosceles triangles
in pairs here.
It's basically
slicing up this angle.
So here, two pairs are
still in, and two pairs
have just been folded out.
And then we're
also-- so remember we
want it to go from
here to up there.
So we're also going to cut
matching little triangles
along the edges, along some
path that goes from this vertex
to that vertex.
There's always some
outside path I can follow,
and so I'm going to cut.
Now, the way we do it, we're
making very shallow triangles
here.
I want to make them match
the triangles that I'm
going to be cutting out here.
So it's got to be
an even number.
I just want to
divide up that edge
into an even number
of tiny pieces.
And then these two match the
size of those two pieces,
and these two match
the size of those two,
so that in particular I could
not touch anything, leave it
the way it used to be, and I
have exactly the old picture.
But alternatively-- and
so it hinges all the ways
it used to be able to hinge.
But alternatively, I can
take these pieces out
and rearrange them like this.
So the pieces are
colored the same
as they were before, except
now instead of putting
these green pieces
in here, I put
the green pieces along
the boundary here.
And we designed them
to fit perfectly.
So these two came from here.
These two came from here,
these two came from there,
these two came from there.
And if you think about
it, then the green piece
has reached around and
can now touch there.
We still have these
orange pieces.
They don't have their
holes to go into before,
but conveniently there
are holes right there.
And that orange chain is
attached right at the top,
right where it needs to be,
so you just stuff them in.
Never mind how
you stuff them in.
We don't have to worry
about continuous motion yet,
that will come later.
And there you go.
So we've moved this
green piece up to there,
and it had to attach it the
same vertex of the green piece.
Now, that's not
quite what I want.
What I'd really like to be
able to do is take a piece
and move it anywhere I want, and
attach it at a different vertex
than from before.
Because in general,
I've just got
to put that green
piece somewhere.
And it's touching
somebody, because I
want to make a
connected polygon.
But it might not want to
attach it at the same vertex.
I might need to turn
it around and attach it
to some other vertex.
It turns out, you just do this
twice and you can fix that.
So this is the
elaboration on step three,
and in general we're
going to maintain
at all times the pieces are
connected together in a tree.
Ultimately, I want an open
chain of hinged polygons.
But I'll worry about
that at the end.
For now, let's take
it to be a tree.
So far it looks like
a chain, but easier
to think about a tree.
And then the key thing
that we are able to do,
what this picture
almost proves--
there's another issue
which I'll get to--
is the ability to effectively
move a rooted subtree
to attach at another
hinge at any other vertex.
What I've drawn here is
we're moving one piece.
But of course, if there
are more pieces attached
to the green thing,
they could come along
for the ride, no problem.
So in computer science we
call that a rooted subtree.
So you have some
collection of pieces,
you have some tree of
pieces hanging off.
Basically if we deleted
this vertex in a tree,
it would detach into two parts.
So here's part A,
here's part B. And maybe
I should actually
give these names.
So here, this is A, this
is B. Here is little a,
and here's little b.
And what I can do is pick
some other point, A prime.
This is a whole bunch of pieces.
I can pick any vertex
of any piece in A,
and I can move B over to there.
I'll just redraw it here.
Here's the old vertex, little a.
Here's the new vertex,
little a prime.
And I can attach the
triangle to be there,
but it still had to attach
at the same root, little b.
What I'd really
like to do, suppose
I have some other
vertex here, B prime,
I'd really like to make B
prime attach to A prime.
This is step one.
Step two is to do
the same thing,
but with the roles
of A and B reversed.
This is a rooted subtree.
It's everything at
this root and below.
But this is also
a rooted subtree.
It's everything at
this root and above.
So I'm going to take
this thing, think
of it as a rooted
subtree, and say,
well I'd like to move
this rooted subtree
to attach at B prime
instead of B. It's exactly
the same operation,
just reversing roles.
Then I will have B
with vertex little b,
vertex little b prime.
And I have my blob A,
where this is A prime
and this is little a,
just rotating pieces.
So look, I've now accomplished
these two chunks of pieces
I've been able to move
subtree b instead of attaching
at little a to little b, it now
attaches at A prime B prime.
This really means I can
take any piece I want--
you can think of B as just
being a single piece, in fact,
but I need this operation
to work for subtrees.
I take a single piece,
I say, well it's
currently attached at this
vertex to this vertex,
but I really want
something else.
I want some other
vertex of B to attach
to some other vertex
of any other piece.
And this will let me do that.
I pick the vertex I
want to attach to,
want to attach from.
I do two of these rooted
subtree moves-- these things--
and then I achieve moving
this piece to anywhere I want.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So it seems
like you're using up
perimeter when you
do each one of these.
PROFESSOR: Yeah
AUDIENCE: So what
happens if you need
to use the same [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the question
is, I'm using up perimeter.
What if I had to use it again?
Because I'm following
one of these long paths,
slicing up pieces like
crazy, and now there
may be some other piece
that was attached to green
and I want to move
it somewhere else.
It might have to follow
along this path again.
And indeed, I will.
You can be smart about
it, or you could say,
well it'll kind of work.
It's just now-- just
think about this picture
and you follow some path.
There's now just more
pieces you visit.
So there's still an outer
boundary to these pieces.
I'm going to think of them
still being in this state,
not in this state.
I can fix it to be
whatever I want.
So I'm going to end up cutting
this into little triangles,
and little triangles,
little triangles.
It's going to get really
messy, really quick.
Every time I do one
of these operations,
I potentially double the
number of pieces or worse.
So this going to be an
exponential number of pieces
if I'm not careful.
You can be careful and
do a little bit better,
but you cannot hope for
a bound in terms of n--
like I would hope for n to
some polynomial in n number
of pieces.
That's not possible,
even for dissections.
If I have a nice, fat
rectangle and I just say,
I want to make it into a
super narrow, skinny rectangle
of the same size,
same area, that's
going to require a lot of
cuts even though n is 4.
So I can't hope for
a polynomial bound.
You can actually get a
pseudo polynomial bound
in a certain sense, but I
don't want to get into that,.
Let's go for existence.
So that was a good question.
We're going to use this
perimeter over and over.
There's unfortunately another
issue with this construction.
This is not enough, because
here I basically assumed
that this green piece was
one solid piece attached
at one point to the orange.
As soon as I do this
operation, there's
now a whole bunch of
pieces here at this vertex.
have to do a more general thing.
This is where it get's messy.
AUDIENCE: [WHISTLES]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
In general, I might
have several hinges
connecting several
pieces over here
to several pieces over there.
Pieces that don't have hinges
I don't care so much about,
but I have to worry about
this in the general case.
It is messier.
So this is the input.
Our goal is to attach these
three pieces, because this
is like a rooted subtree here.
Initially, this may have
just been one piece,
but it's going to get
cut up pretty quickly.
So I've got to
deal with the case
that there are these three
pieces simulating one.
Maybe there's other
stuff hanging off,
that's not a big deal.
And I need to move this entire
bulk hinge somewhere else.
Where are we going?
It looks like the top.
Yeah, little b prime.
So here we're attached to B,
we want to attach to b prime.
It can be done.
It's a little trickier, because
more things have to match up.
So again, we're
going to slice out
from the corner of green,
the corner of purple,
the corner of yellow.
But our pieces are going
to look a little different.
So for green, the
first piece will still
make just skinny triangles.
You can barely see them,
but they are triangles.
And they're again trying to
match the edge lengths over
here.
So we're walking along the
path, same path as before.
So we just cut up a
bunch of skinny triangles
to make that work.
But purple one, it's
not going to work
if we just did that
for all of them.
There just aren't enough
slots to put things,
because really you want to
traverse that boundary three
times.
And here you can't just
do it one at a time.
I won't work, you'll
get an infinite loop.
So what we do is, each of
the little triangles that
would have come out of here we
actually split into two parts.
It may be easiest to
see on the yellow.
There's a triangle,
and then there's
this non-convex
quadrilateral, a little kite.
It just fits on top
of the triangle.
If you glue them together,
you get a regular old triangle
and it fits in here
just like before.
But I take that triangle,
I cut it into two parts.
I do that for both
purple and yellow.
But notice, this
yellow triangle is
bigger than this purple
triangle a little bit.
How much bigger?
Well, it's designed so
that this yellow triangle
is the same size as these
two pieces put together.
And this triangle
is the same size
as this piece put
together with itself.
In general, the triangle
at the next level
up will be the same
size as the two
pieces from the previous level,
except here there's only one.
Why?
Because we want to do
this so that they all fit.
If you take just the quad parts
of everybody and the triangle
of the last guy, then that
triangle will fit into the quad
of the next one , which will fit
into the quad of the next one
perfectly.
Because as far as this
yellow quad is concerned,
that purple plus
green is the same size
as purple plus purple, which
was a regular triangle.
This triangle is supposed
to be the same size
as that yellow triangle.
So from the viewpoint
of this yellow quad,
it's just wants
a mate like this,
which is the same as a
mate like this, which
is the same as a mate like this.
And so those stack in, and
they perfectly fit along.
So the triangles we end up
cutting out of the perimeter
here are the biggest size.
And then you can squeeze
them all together
like this, and boom, you get
your alternate dissection.
Then the other fun part,
what you're left with
is just the triangles from each
of the colors except the green.
And conveniently, it just works.
There's a little
more work to do,
because you see there's
also these red pieces.
Where did those come from?
Just more stuff.
I see where they came
from, up there at C3.
A little corner got cut out.
Oh, it's such a mess.
But the idea is, well,
the purple triangles
are the same size as
the green triangle.
So they can fit in the green
piece and fill in these holes.
And then well, the
yellow triangles
are the same size as the
purple triangles when
you add them together-- that's
what we cut out of here--
and so the yellow just fits in
there and fills in this space.
And so we just shifted by one.
The trouble is, the yellow guys
we don't quite have enough.
And for that we cut out
some corner up there just
to fill them back in.
So you could just stick
the red thing back
into the red vertex,
nothing changes.
Or you can take the
red guys, stick them
into the yellow
triangle, and in the end
we successfully move
a rooted subtree
from anywhere to anywhere.
Lots of things to check
here, but if you stare at it
enough it works.
And it works for
any value of three.
Here we were talking about
three pieces, three hinges,
but you can do it for any count.
That's the gadget.
And good, we've just enough time
to talk about slenderifying.
So if we do this over
and over, move each piece
to wherever you want, move all
the pieces to where you want
for target shape, then do it
for the next target shape,
then do it for the
next, you'll still
be able to go to
all the old foldings
but you can also
go to the new ones.
The last step is
how do we subdivide
to make our thing slender?
And so we have
some tree hinging.
It's not a chain.
We want to also make it a
chain and make it slender,
because slender only works
if it's a chain, not a tree.
So we have some
tree pieces here.
I've drawn two pieces to
make it a little simpler,
but this really
works for anything.
It's super simple.
Triangulate the pieces,
just because triangles
are easier to think about.
Then for each triangle,
cut to its centroid,
where you can fit
the largest disk.
If you do that, each of these
three angles will be obtuse.
So as long as that's
the apex of the triangle
and this is the base--
those are the base edges--
it will be slender
because it's obtuse.
Or if might be 90
degrees, maybe.
Maybe not even that.
I think it's always
strictly obtuse.
So you do that for
each of the triangles,
and then you just walk
around the outside boundary
and say, well, just hinge
things together in that order.
So I'm going to have this
triangle hinge to this one,
hinge up there around.
So I just walked around
the outside boundary.
Now, the key thing to
check is that every hinge
that was here still exists here.
It's still possible
to fold there.
And we just got more
hinges, no big deal.
Just like before,
the constructions
we've been doing, we've
been cutting up the pieces,
adding hinges, but preserving
all the old hinges.
Therefore, any motion
that was possible
before is still possible.
And furthermore, this is now a
slenderly adorned open chain,
we know its configuration
space is connected,
so all those things
that we knew could
exist-- it could be like this
or it could instantaneously
move to here-- now we
know there's actually
continuous motion from
everywhere everywhere.
And this kind of
a fun culmination
of all this linkage stuff,
with Carpenter's Rule,
with slender adornments,
all these powerful tools,
we build up universal hinge
dissections, basically
transformers that can
fold from in this case 2D
shape to any other
collection of 2D
shapes you want of equal area.
And again, you can generalize it
to 3D, although this will work.
Any section you have in
3D will be hingeable,
but dissections get
a little bit harder.
You need not just that
the volumes are the same,
but something else
called the [INAUDIBLE]
is the same, which I
don't want to get into.
That's hinges and dissections.
Any questions?
All right, turn in
your problem set.